hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be a video all about Sansa Stark and
Littlefinger in season seven he is her
final boss so we got to talk about why
she needs to take revenge on him
is going to be a whole lot more Game of
Thrones stuff happening in the next
couple months as they wind down filming
so be sure to subscribe to make sure you
get all the Game of Thrones stuff
there's a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber we have a comment on this
video I'm giving away copies of the
enhanced editions of the book so I'll
explain at the end of the video but be
sure to click that belt when Abel alerts
so you don't miss anything so Callum
star has this very important quote when
she's speaking to Robb Stark during the
War of the five kings we lose the world
and died away for the time
[Music]
show them how it few tears fatigue she
is talking about the Lannisters in that
context but then later Littlefinger as
he's talking to Sansa trying to talk her
into marrying Ramsay does it really give
her much of an option talks about taking
revenge for her family
you'll be running all your life terrible
things happen to a family and you weep
sit alone in a darkened room mourning
their fates who've been a bystander to
tragedy from the day they executed your
father stop being a bystander Jimmy
stop running
no chocolate in the world unless we make
it
you love your family then them
the real irony here is that everything
that Littlefinger has done instigating
all the major conflicts in Westeros has
led to the deaths of her family directly
so he is the person she needs to take
revenge against let's take a trip
through Littlefinger memory lane going
back to before the show started so you
know about how he was fostered with the
Tully's with Kallen and Lysa
Liza was obsessed with him he was
obsessed with Catelyn but she was
betrothed to Brandon Stark when it was
determined when Catelyn would eventually
marry Brandon in the future Littlefinger
outright challenged him for her hand
lost hard core landed on his ass looking
at him today he probably wouldn't last
in a fight against Podrick so they gave
on a day to recover he was only about 15
years old at the time and then sent him
away without getting to say goodbye to
Catelyn so he's still obsessed with her
knew he wasn't going to be able to get
her because he was so lowborn so hatched
his long term con to make it to the
small Council in orchestrate events in
the kingdom to bring about his arrive to
the Iron Throne with Catelyn at his side
he told that story to Sasha at the end
of season six I have a dream in my head
me on the Iron Throne with you beside me
that was Catelyn in that dream until
recently but going back in time when he
was recovering from his wounds with
Brandon
he slept with Lysa she became pregnant
but her father forced her to drink the
moon T so that deepened her obsession
with him he used that later to
orchestrate the death of Jon Arryn he
had a much bigger plan in play to
destabilize the Kingdom during season 1
Jon Arryn was just part of that but he
convinced Lysa that they could be
together if he were to die so she
poisoned him he dies orchestrating the
events that we see at the beginning of
season 1 where Ned Stark is brought to
King's Landing as the new hand of the
king Littlefinger is still the master of
coin trying to deepen the realms debt so
that it will dis table eyes and he can
orchestrate a grand plan that would
culminate in him taking the Iron Throne
but there are a couple big steps along
the way he has to disable eyes the
kingdom he has to throw them into war so
he sells out
Head Start so that's the first thing are
really the biggest thing that she should
kill him for for orchestrating events
that led to the death of her father and
then outright throwing him under the bus
betraying him in the last moments
the next big slap in the face is when
little finger comes to Catelyn during
season two offering ned stark's remains
as recompense and comes on to her she
rejects him outright this is the
beginning of him shifting his attention
to Sansa Stark because as she's growing
up she's looking more and more like
Catelyn and then he comes to the
conclusion during season 3 that as he's
been named Lord of Harrenhal for
brokering this deal with the Lannisters
in the Tyrells that he now has the power
to move to the Vale to offer himself to
Lysa Arryn who has no husband right now
so he thinks long-term that Sansa will
be a more powerful political marriage
than Lysa even though the Vale has those
forces it's still a very big place very
important but it's just a stepping stone
to Winterfell which was his ultimate
goal which is why he sends her to marry
Ramsay in the way they explain a TV show
Littlefinger didn't truly know how bad
he was but he didn't seem all that sorry
are all that quick to help Santa when he
heard about what was happening to her so
you don't really follow up on that till
season 6 when she looks like she's
getting ready to stab him in the face
but it's just a prelude to what she's
going to be doing to him later she fed
Ramsay to his dogs imagine what she's
going to do to Littlefinger eventually
but the whole point in putting Sansa in
Winterfell was in regaining control of
Winterfell via political marriage that
was little fingers in had things not
gone well for him or had the Battle of
the bastards gone the other way he would
have immediately turned tail and
brokered an alliance with the Bolton's
so that they could eventually form
another alliance with the Tyrells and
what is happening now sort of the
disabled ization of the throne in
orchestrate events is they could call a
Great Council and get everyone to trust
him so that he could present Sansa is
the next candidate for ruler of the
realm with someone else or eventually
with him the problem is is that she
would need a suitors is a good book very
about Jon Snow or Aegon being a
Targaryen suitor for her in the books
but because the TV show has changed
things so much I'm not expecting it to
be
even close to what's happening in the
books but every twist and turn along the
way in Littlefinger's planned to take
the Iron Throne with Kallen and then
eventually with Sansa has dealt their
family so many wounds that Santa has a
limitless reason to kill him so looking
at her arc now she went from being the
silly young girl in season one to having
the innocence literally beaten out of
her until today when she's learning to
play little fingers game
did you kill Joffrey did I catch me I've
been in the various week analogy
until helped me with this conspiracy do
you remember that lovely necklace Dontos
gave you I don't suppose you notice that
a stone was missing after the feast the
poison
I don't understand the Lannisters gave
you wealth power Joffrey made you the
Lord of Harrenhal a man with no motive
is a man no one suspect always keep your
foes confused if they don't know who you
are or what you want they can't know
what you plan to do next
so really the only thing is sophie
Turner has said that Sansa want is
recognition in what's going on her role
in the Battle of the bastards the fact
that she helped broker the alliance that
allowed them to win the battle she
doesn't seem to be getting that so even
though she's a little upset with Jon
Snow and does not feel that he is fit to
rule the kingdom she isn't out to get
Jon Snow in the corner you can almost
see the calculus that Littlefinger is
doing in his head to try and turn the
situation to his benefit and that would
be turning Sansa against Jon Snow but
ultimately their family and what is the
show done with the big female
protagonist the last couple of season
it's shown them rising above things
tearing down the patriarchy so what
would Santa's next move then be it would
be to cast off her little finger
shackles but there are a couple things
that she can do to accomplish that one
she could out him to the rest of the
kingdom that he's responsible for
orchestrating all these terrible events
Jon Snow would execute him on the spot
he was ready to execute Melisandre on
the spot if you were to learn about
little fingers for sponsibility in Ned
Stark's death that would be the end of
it there will be no more conversation so
let me know in the comments what do you
think is going to have to happen before
Sansa openly moves against Littlefinger
because right now it seems like she's
slowly using him as a chess piece like
he really wants her and she knows that
so she's going to try and use that to
her advantage but something really big
still has to happen before she outright
tries to kill him and that would
probably involve marrying the sweet
Robin
so that would secure that alliance she
wouldn't need Littlefinger anymore and
she would rule over the Vale which is
what Littlefinger is effectively doing
now as steward for sweet Robin
technically the other lords of the Vale
really hate him but because sweet Robin
likes them there's nothing that they can
do about it because he has so much
influence over him but if Sansa were
able to turn sweet Robin then they
wouldn't need Littlefinger anymore so
they're just a couple power
days left in season seven for Sansa
Littlefinger is her final boss and
getting vengeance and justice for her
family in everything that's happened
since the beginning of season one so if
there any other Game of Thrones Season
seven or any other bonus videos you guys
want me to do just let me know in the
comments there's going to be so much
stuff happening in the next couple of
months we're going to get a trailer
really soon I know everybody wants to
see some actual footage from season
seven they're almost done filming right
now so they congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner sword of the
morning you in one of the enhanced
editions of the books please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there's a new round in this video I'll
announce the winners the next time I
post the Game of Thrones video so really
cool stuff coming there was some new
Doctor Strange Thor Ragnarok that just
dropped so that'll be my first video
tomorrow then we'll do some new flash
and I'll just post updates on bonus
videos as we go along while you wait for
that you can click here to learn about
the brand new Targaryen book George R
Martin is doing later this year and you
can click here to learn about the extra
episodes and stuff that we're going to
be getting during season 8 of the TV
show thank you so much for watching
everybody let's not bot I'll see you in
the next video